i i think it by this stage it is clear
that there is not an aspect of western
culture that has not been
assaulted at such a fundamental and
dishonest level
that if you were to continue this game
there's just nothing left nothing
[Music]
hello everyone i'm pleased to be talking
today to mr douglas murray
who is associate editor of the spectator
and is now based in new york his latest
publication the madness of crowds was a
bestseller his last publication the
madness of krauts was a bestseller and
book of the year for the times and the
sunday times
is the book before that the strange
death of europe immigration identity
islam was published by bloomsbury in may
2017.
it spent almost 20 weeks on the sunday
times bestseller list and was the number
one bestseller in non-fiction
douglas and i have spoken several times
before uh publicly on my podcast and for
unheard and
he also moderated a discussion i had
with sam harris
i've just finished his latest book which
is not out yet
the war on the west
when is it out douglas
it's out on the 26th of april so um
hopefully by the time people see this it
will be out
yeah
so um let's that's what we're going to
talk about today your new book i read it
yesterday and i thought i might start
with
something
technical in some sense terminological
it might be regarded as a pretty
inflammatory title the war on the west
and maybe we'll start with that
what do you mean by war and why use that
term
um essentially the that's interesting i
thought you were going to start with
with the west which is well we'll do
that
naughty one next
untangle yeah well we'll do that next
for sure uh
war uh
because what i s what i say in the book
is that
this is what we've been going through
we've been going through a war
on everything to do with the foundations
of the west everything to do with the
results of the western inheritance
and when i say that of course i mean
the war as i do it bit by bit on
western history
a war on western peoples a war on
western culture
uh war on western religion and
philosophy
this position that i argue that we've
come to in the present age where
everything is bad if it came from us
let me say
us in the west and everything is good so
long as it hasn't come from us
now i should stress by the way that what
i'm describing here is western
anti-westernism uh there are plenty of
other forms of anti-westernism
russian anti-westernism there's chinese
anti-westernism all sorts of other kinds
but the one that i think is most
interesting partly because it's so
pathological
is what i'm really writing about here
which is western anti-westernism why we
in the west have arrived at this strange
place where where we venerate everything
so long as it's not our own
we respect things so long as it hasn't
been produced by the society that also
produced us
and i do think this is a fundamental
assault i think is fundamental assault
as i try to demonstrate in the book on
all of the foundations the principles
the foundational figures the heroes
the great stories the great the the
great themes of the west even have all
come in recent decades
under this just relentless assault
and i try to explain why why i think
that's happened it's not an entirely new
phenomenon as you know i mean it's been
a strain of western thought arguably for
for some centuries if not longer but
that in recent decades it's picked up a
pace and it's picked up a pace for some
very obvious reasons
after the colonial era it was inevitable
that there was going to be an
anti-colonial backlash a post-colonial
movement
but that's lingered and turned into
something else
as of all of the other backlashes that i
lay out so i do think it's i think it's
a i think it's a it's a complete and
fundamental assault on everything that
the west has produced and and i think
that's why it's deserving of of of the
term
so to to what end
well that's a very interesting question
because of course it's a different aim
for different people i mean one of the
people i write about at one point in the
book is um fanon uh franz fernandez
distinguished and highly cited
postcolonial author who like edward
saeed had a profound influence
in the academy uh the forward to his
last book was written by satra
he was a
very very um impressive in many ways
figure um but his his version of what
should happen in the post-colonial era
was for instance i mean basically
entirely marxist and it's one of the
it's one of the ironies i try to tease
out about this that for instance
if in the post-colonial era people had
argued that
societies that have been colonized
should be returned to a pre-colonial
condition
with a return to let's say
more of the native uh
political and other habits then that
would have been one thing but writers
like fanon were not doing that they they
they were arguing that the answer to the
colonial era was was marxism
and of course that that has this
tremendous irony doesn't it which is
that they say well this one form of of
westernism western colonialism must be
replaced because it's western and what
we'll replace it with is
western marxism
uh and and so that's that's just one of
the motivations i think was a very
strong motivation certainly in the
immediate period of the post-colonial
era
there are different versions of it now
of course there's the
let's say the social one
the one where
it's just rather gauche
i mean of course famously writers like
orwell pointed this out many decades ago
rather gosh to celebrate anything about
your own society and indeed regarded as
being slightly backward a sign of a sort
of
low resolution figure that you would do
such a thing whereas the veneration of
other cultures was a was as a with a
demonstration of sophistication a
sophisticate would do that
but we do end up in this position uh
today
which is it was much more dangerous than
that
uh one of the reasons i do the assault
on western history and do do it also by
individuals you know the figures it used
to be and suddenly in my own lifetime
i'm sure in yours jordan the
some of the absolutely foundational
heroes of western history have come in
for specific assault and you could ask
yourself well
maybe that's because they're overdue
some reckoning
and i think it's far more than that and
i try to show that i try to show for
instance that
the interpretation of
say thomas jefferson
or winston churchill or abraham lincoln
has actually become
an assault based on the following
premise that if we can take down
churchill we sort of can get to the
roots of taking down british patriotism
if we get if we assault abraham lincoln
we've offend essentially not and done
thomas jefferson we've not just
assaulted them
we've actually assaulted something that
is the absolute root of the american
ideal
the the heroic story the heroic figure
and then there's this further layer of
that which is not just with individuals
but with whole societies so that for
instance instead of understanding the
history of racism as well racism is a
highly regrettable and ugly human trait
which is consistent across all human
societies that we know about uh and it
is a part of western history
instead the whole of western history is
made into a history of racism in which
racism was the guiding force
when
as i explained the book or any fair
estimate would see it as being an
element within western history but
by no means the thing that drove western
history so it's this sort of thing okay
so let's let's concentrate on that then
in terms of the values that you regard
as uh being under assault in this war
what do you think the canonical values
are that are the subject of this intense
criticism now and you described marxism
itself which is also a branch of western
thought interestingly enough as
fundamental to this criticism
so
what
if it isn't the marxists basically make
the claim that
something like
the claim that
history and human institutions and
perhaps individuals as well are to be
understood as manifestations of their
class identity so as some form of group
identity for for the classical marxists
it was class identity and then history
is to be viewed as the
battle between
an oppressor class and an oppressed
class and the oppressor class is
motivated by the desire to exploit the
the victimized class
and that's base and then that's been
transferred i would say to some degree
in recent years to
terminology that replaces economic class
with race but basically makes the same
arguments does that seem okay so
if
so
the claim then is that the central
motivation is something like the will to
use compulsion
in the service of
group centered goals i guess
what's the western counter claimant and
why
so that's one question is there a
western counter claim and why should we
reject that analysis of history given
that things do
get corrupted by power
well
i i quote in the opening and um and
later on in the book as you know a
phrase of nature which i sort of add to
from the genealogy of morals when
nietzsche refers it um
in passing but i think he's such a
remarkable phrase i wanted to
to bring it out and throw it to the
forefront he talks in the genealogy of
morals of of people who talk about
justice but mean revenge
now this seems to me to be an
extraordinarily pertinent insight to our
era when you when you actually when you
talk about the some of the scholars and
writers that i i
try to tear into in this book
uh they have
i'm thinking of figures like ibrahim x
kendi robin d'angelo
um
quite a number of others like you could
go on listing but these are some of the
main ones
they're simply not interested it's clear
in a sort of fair analysis of the west
or its history or its traditions or its
claims
they're interested in a form of revenge
and and some of them are perfectly open
about that i mean i mean candy is
perfectly open about the fact that in
response to one thing it might be
necessary to punish another group
he says it completely completely frankly
in in his most famous book how to be
ironically titled in
inappropriately titled how to be an
anti-racist
um
so and it's extremely clear from the
work of other people in this movement
people like um hannah nicole jones of
the 1619 project what you're really
talking about you're certainly talking
about with the people tearing down the
heroes of the west
is is people are saying okay
you had your go
and now we're going to have ours and
we're going to see how you like it
how you like being talked about in
extraordinarily racist terms how you
like being lumped in and homogenized as
a group for instance white people or
western people western traditions
and again this isn't an entirely new
thing i point out again with one of the
most prominent postcolonial writers
edward syed who
every benighted student has had to study
and almost any university has come
across orientalism at some point and one
of saeed's fundamental critiques of the
west is that it sort of it essentializes
people in the east
and you know there's quite a lot of
points to make about that but one of
them is he's extremely good at
decentralizing people in the west you
know he'll refer in passing said to for
instance your average 19th century
european
what the hell was an average 19th
century european any more than a
average 19th century
person in africa or
the arabian peninsula you know
people of this
this revenge kind were extraordinarily
keen to use tools which they claimed to
deprecate so long as they furthered
their particular political goals
and i think that they exposed themselves
again and again and the problem in
recent years as i see it in the west is
that this process of revenge has taken
on this exceptionally gleeful
uh attitude
people like deangelo
visibly audibly cannot believe the luck
they have that they can get away with
saying that the things that they do
and when and the fact that when asked to
provide evidence they say things like
d'angelo did recently in an interview
there's a collective glee in the white
body when black bodies are punished
you know and her interviewer who happens
to be black asks her for evidence of
this she has none so she just makes
another outrageous claim
and this has become this has become part
of it
okay so let's let's go into this as
deeply as we can so i was thinking when
reading your book about
let's start with the issue of slavery
and it's certainly the case that
the people that you're describing and
the
intellectual
and marxist influence types
who criticize the
the more traditional institutions of the
west
accept it as a given that slavery is
wrong
and so you could imagine there might be
two reasons for that one reason would be
one group should not have the upper hand
over another
or at least if you're the group that's
in the uh oppressed class
you might not want that to be the case
and the other argument is there's
something intrinsically wrong with
slavery as such
but that but at the individual level
and so i guess one of the things that
struck me is that
unless you believe the second
you're just trying to swap one form of
slavery for another and it isn't also
clear why it's wrong
and slavery is wrong if you believe that
the individual should be sovereign able
to make choices able to make free and
unconstrained choices that aren't
subject to the arbitrary will of another
but to believe that you have to believe
that there is such a thing as the
individual that's the right unit of
analysis and that the idea that that
individual is valuable and sovereign in
some fundamental sense is true and then
when i think that i think
there isn't
anywhere in the world where that idea
has been expressed more clearly than in
the west
and so
it's so interesting to see people object
to slavery and object to the use of
arbitrary power by
one group over another
but also to reject wholesale the
individualism the notion of individual
value that's at the heart of the western
enterprise that seems to be the basis
for the rejection of slavery per se you
do point out for example that it wasn't
obvious that karl marx objected to
slavery on moral grounds
so so it seems it's too obvious to even
be asked why is slavery wrong but when
everything obvious is up for grabs then
it's perfectly reasonable to ask that
and and so
part of the problem with
setting the group against the individual
is that you see that the people who do
that seem to invalidate their own moral
claim that what they're opposing is
wrong like on what basis is it wrong
and does that seem like a reasonable
position to you yes i mean
one of the most fascinating things about
this i go into in the section on slavery
in the book is that of course
um historically speaking it would have
been highly unusual to be proposed to
slavery in almost any era
and there were lots of reasons for that
i mean you you first of all have the one
of the questions as you know that i
delve into at one point in the book is
why are the enlightenment philosophers
under particular attack at the moment
and there are various explanations you
could give for that one is that there is
a genuine overdue reckoning uh that
there is a form of enlightenment let's
say fundamentalism at the moment that
views
that views figures of the enlightenment
as as particularly needing this sort of
scouring and
reapproach another is that they happen
to have the misfortune to live in an era
in which both the slave trade and
colonialism currently seen as the two
great wrongs of history of the west
were going on
and that they didn't spend enough of
their time countering them and that
emanuel kant should have spent more time
addressing slavery and less time
addressing all of the questions that he
addressed and that rather than talking
about superstition and trying to pull
that apart david hume should have been
interested in colonialism and on and on
so that's another explanation and a
third explanation which i think is
perhaps more persuasive is that actually
if you go for the enlightenment
philosophers you get to the one of the
absolutely key things to assault if
you're going to assault the west which
are the ideas of rationalism and reason
and the application of the scientific
method and much more but but but the
reason i mention this is because of of
course what's what's so fascinating is
that there is there is
there are two aspects of the slavery
thing in particular need to be delved
into one is that thing off well
everybody did it throughout history
um and there's a counter which candy
among others do which is well western
slavery was worse because it was
race-based and by the way that's
absolute nonsense i mean
countless societies had effectively
race-based slavery and indeed it's going
on today in the middle east and in
africa um but but but there but there
was a specific reason actually why
during the enlightenment period and i i
cite thomas jefferson on this because
he's a very interesting figure trying to
think this through as they were going
through it one of the reasons why thomas
jefferson is so insecure interesting
because he is one of the most thoughtful
people of his era
was still not aware of whether or not
there was an answer or which way the
answer went to what was still a live
conversation then which was the
monogenesis um
uh and uh um polygenesis argument that
was the argument over whether or not all
the the human races were from the same
stock as it were or whether
we were all from different lines
uh that debate seems obvious to us now
because it got answered later in the
19th century uh it wasn't obvious at
that time and people like jefferson were
trying to do what they could with it so
there was a sort of there was one
version of the defense of slavery which
was
well these are all totally different
people but then of course you have to
counter that with the fact that and
again voltaire made this point what is
the greater evil
to sell somebody and buy somebody of a
different
country a different race and so on
or to sell your neighbor or your brother
or the member of your community now of
course
this is a
just as it is
just as it was when voltaire asked the
question it's an exceedingly
uncomfortable question to ask today and
i don't ask it in order to to say well
there's an obvious answer but as
everybody knows the slave trade only
existed because people in africa were
selling their brothers and their
neighbors and raiding neighboring towns
of people who looked exactly like them
and selling them to other black people
in africa some of whom ended up in the
slave trade going across the atlantic
many more of whom went through the slave
trade that went to arabia so so
it took an awfully long time for our
species to even begin and we're not
there yet by any means i've met i've met
people in my own life who are slaves
were born slaves
in africa and elsewhere
um this is by no means solved by our
species but we look back at it now as if
it was perfectly obvious
well look okay so my understanding of
of
the history of ideas in the deepest
sense is that
it's very difficult for people
first of all to understand that there is
a universally
valid
human essence across cultures right and
so
most
isolated peoples have regarded their own
citizens as human and everyone else who
isn't part of that group as
not fully human
and
to to to develop a universal
system of value despite that proclivity
has been extraordinarily difficult and
then to further
make the case that each person
regardless of their social status and
power and all of that
is also characterized by something
that is best termed intrinsic worth
that's associated with their personal
sovereignty is or their individual
sovereignty is also an extraordinarily
difficult
idea to conceptualize
and then
but
so first of all we shouldn't be lulled
into thinking that as you pointed out
that those are human norms in some sense
they're not
quite the contrary and then
i do believe it is the case that first
of all perhaps in the religious domain
we can talk about that later and then
later in the political domain
that notion of divine individual worth
was developed and instituted in social
institutions most effectively and in
some sense solely
in the west and yes and
we could get into that in one angle you
talk about the british empire's
attempt to eradicate slavery worldwide
and also that that was driven by
christian notions and and by christians
specifically and that it also occurred
at great expense in relationship to the
british empire's function
yes so maybe you could just walk through
that a bit we could delve into that yes
this is a this is an important
particularly important one because uh
yes first of all as you well know many
of the people like william wilberforce
who are most prominent in arguing the
case for the abolition of slavery uh uh
were driven
comprehensively by their christian faith
and so you know as my late friend rabbi
jonathan sachs used to say that the the
claim that
morality is self-evident is
self-evidently untrue
um
these people were driven
by a specific idea of morality and a
specific set of values and indeed
virtues and it's a modern um
it's a modern myth
that we would have got there anyway but
the sanctity of the individual the
sanctity of the individual life and the
autonomy of every individual the
necessity of every individual having
autonomy was at the absolute base of the
of the desire first of all
to uh
ban slavery in the british empire
and then
and it was a i guess maybe people would
say well you would say that wouldn't you
douglas having been born and brought up
in the uk but
a pretty remarkable thing that the
british empire then decided to spend a
considerable amount of blood and
treasure policing the high seas in order
to to stop slavery elsewhere
uh british sailors losing their lives um
boarding ships without sales that they
would search the cargo holds for and
discover were for instance a brilliant a
brazilian uh slave trading ship trying
to sneak through in disguise because
brazil didn't get rid of slavery until
the 1880s formerly
and and and britain police the seas for
this for many years uh thousands of
sailors lost their lives and in the end
as i cite in the book the actual cost
of eradicating the slave trade has been
shown by
a number of modern historians to have
actually cost britain more first of all
in the actual uh um endeavor
secondly most importantly in the in the
uh the paying out the buying out effect
for your companies engaged in the slave
trade in order to make sure that they
didn't continue their their trade and
thirdly in the increased prices that
everybody in britain had to pay
throughout the 19th century because of
the need
to pay for goods that were coming from
non-slave trading places these ended up
being
an exercise more costly
than than the benefits accrued
during the period of slavery so the
reason why i mention this isn't actually
just because of the way i speak or the
fact that i happen to come from the uk
it's because it then gets us to this
very interesting question which is what
would restitution ever look like
and what i'm what i've noticed and what
i as you know jordan a number of times
in the book go into is this question of
reparations as it's currently called
what we might also call a sort of what
would restitution look like on a number
of historic wrongs and i've been very
struck in the last two decades in
particular
by the fact that we have people and
again nietzsche puts his finger on it
with uncanny precision i'm struck by the
number of people who
who who rip at long closed wounds
rip them open and then
scream at everyone about how hurt they
are
because
in actual fact on a whole range of
issues of what we're now reminded are
historic wrongs something like
considerable restitution happened an
awfully long time ago
i mean you still hear people saying it's
extremely popular in american discourse
that america never addressed the issue
of slavery and you know you think well
fighting a long and bloody civil war
about it would have been one obvious way
that they've clearly tried to address it
and even that today is is pooh-poohed a
number of condemned historians say oh it
wasn't really about slavery it was a
different power struggle it never is
about the thing that the thing was about
but but i'm very keen to address these
uh ugly difficult corners of it because
they say if you are interested in
restitution of making making atonement
for any any wrongs in the past you have
to look at what actually has already
happened in the past by way of atonement
well there's also a
christian slash western or
judeo-christian slash
western
philosophy of atonement
and
that is that you atone for your
shortcomings and perhaps for the unequal
distribution of talents by trying to
live a responsible generous productive
and honest life
and that it's actually a matter of
individual
moral striving rather than something
that should be conceptualized at the
group level and so i'm struck again and
still i mean it i cannot understand
if you accept the notion that
the willingness of one group to oppress
another is in some
measure a human universal it's deeply
characteristic of our history and that
the
reason that that's wrong is that
individuals shouldn't be subject to
arbitrary compulsion partly because it
deprives the rest of us of their
potential value as free agents and
partly because it's
that and and partly because it's it
transgresses against part of their
essential nature that's intrinsically
valuable
you can't oppose slavery on moral
grounds as far as i can tell without
implicitly accepting those axioms and so
then it's so striking to me that the
people who are simultaneously accusing
the west of these uniquely awful
predilections
accept one of the great
uh propositions of the west as central
to their entire moral doctrine and then
they accept it so centrally they don't
even notice that it's true they just
think it's self-evident
well it's not so self-evident why why
shouldn't i oppress someone if i can get
away with it
and why shouldn't my group
right and and then
and then we we have the one now which is
the form of oppression that presents
itself in the guise of the victim
i
i constantly come back in this book to
the people who present themselves as
victims and are clearly the bullies
um
people who who claim to be suffering
from historic wrongs because it gives
them a dominance that they would not
otherwise have
i mean let me give you
two uh quick quite significant examples
of this
uh two of the most celebrated writers of
the last generation in america are tan
heezy coates and ibrahimo x kendi both
of them have been recipients of
macarthur genius awards um um kendy is
now the only holder apart from the late
ellie wiesel of
the late nobel prize winner and
holocaust survivor of one of the most
prestigious chairs in an american ivy
league university um uh the the the both
of them have written memoirs that have
been bestsellers and are highly fated
and cited everywhere um and both of them
have an origin story of racism that is
absolutely risible
um in the case of coates he describes a
moment in one of his memoirs of getting
into an elevator with his young child
and a white woman gets into the elevator
and he says behaves dismissively towards
the child
and coates describes how he wants to
sort of fling this woman against the
wall and sort of throttle her for this
act of racism and at no point suggests
that actually it's possible that
the woman was having a bad day and it
didn't matter who the child was or
or that
she was partially sighted or anything
you know
this immediate assumption this is racism
we suffered it and we suffered it so
appallingly i'm going to get a chapter
of my book out of it and ibrahim x
kendi's origin story of racism is
equally visible and it's that when he
was at primary school in the us
um as a child on one occasion a teacher
in the classroom
uh called on a white girl when a quiet
black girl in the class also had her
hand up and wasn't called upon and kenny
gets an entire chapter out of this
and my suggestion on these cases is
these people are presenting
extremely minimal stories
reasonably small stories of i don't by
the way and i don't deny that racism
exists in some forms today in america as
in all societies but they present these
reasonably small examples of racism in
order to present themselves as a victim
and then present themselves also as the
judge and jury over everybody else
currently alive
uh
there's it's also very different to
say
that institutions are
corrupted or tempted by
uh
the willingness to use power the
motivation to use power and that one of
the manifestations of that is various
form of uh arbitrary oppression
and to claim that that's the central
guiding principle of the institutions
and the societies
and then
and that that also begs the question
well
if you
criticize the west let's say
for its
grounding in willingness to use
arbitrary power and compulsion
what do you propose as an alternative
and why do you believe that alternative
exists
does the alternative only exist outside
of
the western structure somehow
what's their ex
what's there except power
it's only power
it's only power and power in this era as
you know jordan comes through the claim
of oppression
that the power is best exerted in our
era first of all by claiming that the
person has been a victim of oppression
and secondly by wielding that alleged
oppression sometimes true oppression but
by wielding it
as a tool to beat others
so that for instance it's also
interesting that the only reason that
works let's say i claim moral virtue
because i'm an anti-racist rather than a
non-racist
well why does that
why does that work for me why do i have
a platform why do i have it
[Music]
if people were psychopathic expressers
of power and that was particularly true
of western people they just say
something like
well yeah what's your point try to do
something about it and you think that's
wrong it's just because you're weak and
i've got the power and i've got you
under my thumb and to hell with you and
your stupid ideas but that isn't what
people do and when they're accused of
being racist in the west they're they're
struck to the heart generally speaking
they're ashamed of themselves they'll
they'll bend over backwards to apologize
they they scour their conscience to see
if they can find any example of where
they might not have abided by the
principle of
divine sovereignty somehow and make
obeisances in every possible direction
and so
that in itself seems to indicate that
the primary claim is fundamentally
untrue
which and as you know i mean i write a
chapter in the book as you know on them
well what everyone else in the world is
doing whilst we're doing this to
ourselves
and
you know one of my favorite examples i i
quote a lay colleague of mine's work on
this is is racism within china and
racism from china about the rest of the
world but there's a term that the
chinese use of wha of white people
that that that roughly translates as
ghosts
um the idea being that i think it's quay
um
and
the
the idea is of course is that white
people aren't really human
like
the simulacrum of a human being but not
the real thing only the chinese people
are the real thing well
well that's really racism for sure
and uh from the most heavily populated
uh um country on earth and and
there's no anyone certainly willing to
use power and one's certainly willing to
use power so this is an oddity
so it looks to me for example i've tried
to make this case that um
the central animating
spirit of the west is
something like the spirit of voluntary
association the spirit of voluntary
cooperation
uncompelled choice recognition of
universal human dignity now we all fall
short of acting that out and instilling
it in our institutions but and i see
that as a reflection of a deeper that
deeper theological claim that we
discussed earlier that each individual
is in some sense of divine worth
intrinsically
and
and and should be treated as
intrinsically worthwhile as a
consequence and and that out of that as
far as i'm concerned
emerges the entire tradition
of natural rights and they're a
delineation of the notion of that
intrinsic worth
that's not the expression of the will to
power it's the precise opposite of that
and so yes
why are we so loath to
give ourselves credit for
the emergence of that idea in our
attempts to abide by it why are we so
prone to guilt in this this regard
firstly because firstly we go about that
thing that it's regarded as being
somewhat um
somewhat gauche and backward and
unsophisticated to take such an attitude
and the second is that we ge
is a sec
and there are many other reasons but a
second is
the completely misinformed idea and this
comes from america in particular i'm
afraid it's what america has been
pumping around the world in recent
decades
the idea that what is what is bad in the
west is uniquely bad and that comes from
a complete and wholesale ignorance not
just of history in the rest of the world
but the rest of the world now i mean a
total startling lack of context i mean
if anything ever suffered from context
collapse in our era it is everything to
do with the west
uh
so that so that it is seen as there's
another element
sorry there's another element that seems
to be me to be worthy of note too
we're tortured
for our moral insufficiency because of
the existence of demonstrable inequality
and the call for equity
is part of the clarion call for the
people who are conducting let's call it
the war on the west
and the proposition there is essentially
marxist that
wealth tends to accumulate in the hands
of fewer and fewer people which happens
to be true although those people differ
the proportion
is small but the people change but
what's so faulty about that in my
estimation
isn't the claim that that inequality
exists or even the claim that
there are negative
aspects of that that might need to be
addressed but the notion that that is
somehow
unique to the social institutions and
the economic institutions of the west i
hate that most particularly because i
think it underestimates the problem you
cannot blame inequality capitalism
no i mean it's foolish yeah absolutely i
mean
let's take the other options on the
table uh the remaining flotsam and
jetsam of the cold war uh
let's say you could say maybe you could
say putin's russia
you can certainly say cuba and a few
other places
what do we reckon is the inequality of
wealth in these countries between
let's say the oligarchs and the average
russian
um
there was a documentary alexander
navalny bravely made before going uh
back to russia and being imprisoned and
he had it released after he got back to
um russia the other month and was
promptly imprisoned uh he had the
release of this documentary called
putin's palace and one of the
extraordinary things which did a lot of
harm for putin at home because people
were genuinely shocked and upset about
this was that putin's palace on the
black sea uh which he's been building
for years the costs of hundreds and
hundreds of millions of dollars
has among other things a vineyard
attached to it and there's a guest area
a guest room near the vineyard and
there's a guest lavatory in the guest
room the vineyard and there's a lavatory
brush there made of gold that costs the
same as the average russian makes in a
year
so
there's just one example of inequality
in russia
we could do
the same thing for cuba
and let's look at all of the other
examples
look at north korea
um
i've seen myself in a country which i
visited many years ago but in a country
where uh the general population starved
by the millions in the 1990s and
the the military elites were able to get
hold on the black market of blue label
johnny walker uh on the most expensive
whiskies on the planet um take any of
them because everyone talks about the
compost colonials i mean of course
post-colonial societies that haven't
gone well they've been post-colonial
societies that have gone very well like
singapore in terms of productivity you
could say that hong kong until very
recently the same thing but let's talk
about the the post-colonial societies
that didn't go well zimbabwe for
instance what was the wealth inequality
in zimbabwe between the the wealth of
mrs mugabe say
and the average zimbabwean
the the average life expectancy in
zimbabwe during robert mugabe's
reign
halved
he's one of the very few leaders in the
world where life expectancy actually
declined faster than people were living
people were on a treadmill that was
getting shorter and shorter with every
step
well what was wealth inequality like
that what's wealth inequality like in
angola these days i mean go anywhere and
it is it is so obscene to present this
as as you say as some kind of phenomenon
of western capitalism
as and as though any other system around
could be better
and and to present it as some sort of
rigorous theory so
all economic systems produce inequality
it seems to be the reflection of a deep
underlying
law
that we don't understand that well about
how
advantage tends to accrue as you accrue
advantage and disadvantage tends to
accrue as you accrue disadvantage
positive feedback loops of some sort yes
all economic systems result in
inequality and different societies have
evolved different mechanisms to deal
with that but the only system that we
know of that's
also produced inequality but also
produced
the cessation of absolute privation
are free market systems and china didn't
manage that until they instituted
instituted free market systems and free
market systems work because sovereign
individuals exercise choice over not
only purchase but also employment
and so
people in the west are guilty about
inequality and
liable to
rape themselves over the coals when its
existence is pointed out but it's partly
because they don't understand how
pernicious the problem really is and
they don't take credit for the fact that
free markets have stopped people from
starving you know it's only eight
percent of people now live
below the u.n line for absolute poverty
compared to 40 percent in ronald
reagan's time that's only
40 years 40 years
and you can you go back to that
phenomenon that again
i don't think there's any evidence that
in modern china the people involved with
the politburo
and the people who've done terribly well
out of the last 20 years
uh since particularly since china
entered the wto i don't think there's
any evidence of
significant fears about inequality
between the chinese elite and the
average person there is something very
specific about the western worry about
inequality which again like the worry
about slavery like the worry about guilt
and historical guilt
is a product of a thing that ought to be
recognized as being a good part of the
machine
if i if if the machine was so pernicious
we wouldn't care about inequality we
would simply say as i'm afraid or we'd
celebrate it even more
which is a perfectly easy thing to do
which is well if i have more it's
because i'm better and the evidence that
i'm better is clearly
that i have more and what's your
evidence for the contrary claim well
people have intrinsic worth it's like
yeah
and you could go to another of the
world's biggest economies uh india uh i
don't know if you've ever been there
it's an extraordinary culture very very
rich a wonderful culture of
just the most extraordinary place to
visit but it also has a form of
inequality which is grotesque to any
western visitor i'm talking of course
about the caste system which exists this
day
which is a form of slavery as well and
which regards people if they're born
into the wrong class as being literally
untouchable
the untouchable class in india
is something you're born into
and you will be in for your whole life
now
is that inequality oh yes is it systemic
hell yes
is is much being done about it not
really
people take a sort of view that
well there's an old joke about princess
margaret once being asked
once hearing somebody refer to an
extraordinarily grand english country
house and the person says imagine this
coming as just an accident of birth and
princess margaret saying birth is no
accident
um now but but but actually that that
view whether it was correctly attributed
or not is regarded by us as being
laughable and visible it's not being
been regarded as being laughable at all
visible in one of the most important
societies in the world today india and
historically that certainly wasn't
regarded as laughable in any sense the
notion that
uh you didn't have
divine value in some sense or ultimate
value as a consequence of your birth
that that was an extraordinarily
difficult idea to supplant uproot and
transform because it that also seemed in
some real sense self-evident
and then the evidence was your success
and i'm afraid here we also get to what
i regard as being one of the
hardest to discuss but most necessary to
identify aspects of what i'm trying to
tackle in this book which is what i go
straight on to in the first chapter
which is what i regard as being and
describe as a now outright war on white
people now of course this is very
difficult to talk about because people
say first of all you're guilty of
self-pity of some kind or or you know
boohoo poor you
um but as i show i think in some
remorseless detail in that chapter um if
you want to if you wanted for some
reason to attack
africa
um
or
everyone from north africa downwards
you would at some point if you were to
be driven by such an animus you would be
attacking black people
um if you decided to turn on
everything to do with chinese culture at
some point you would be attacking
chinese people
and so it is in the case of the west
that since historically the west has
been predominantly populated not
entirely but predominantly populated by
white people the assault on the west has
to include and now does include an
extraordinarily ugly and increasingly
ugly assault on white people
whereby the own in in societies which
quite rightly abhor racism
the only group of people against whom
racism is completely acceptable has
become white people and this is this is
to my mind one of the great unsavables
but necessary to address issues of our
time because it seems to me that this
can't go on much longer
it's an
extraordinarily dangerous game that's
being played
and one with
such negative consequences not least the
consequences of likely backlash that it
has to be had out in the open at the
point at which you are deciding people's
futures in the workplace based on their
on whether they're white or not and that
being white means you're marked down
but application to schools and
universities
involves you being marked down if you're
white
but access to medical care
as i give examples of in the book
you will be deprived of it if you happen
to be white in certain jurisdictions and
this and very much more is absolute
poison
in our societies and i think is one of
the things that has to be addressed
uh if we really don't like racism we
have to tackle the rise
of this new racism which has become
totally acceptable and every day
well to also to identify
western ideas let's say as somehow white
means that you
to the degree that those
ideas have a universal value which might
even be the universal value
say of
making the case that slavery is wrong
you have to deny them to other people
who aren't of that race
right you you you
you contaminate them irretrievably i've
seen attempts for example to make the
case that
the emphasis on logic and excellence is
somehow white and that to accept those
uh values as
paramount
[Music]
means that you've just fallen under the
sway of a certain kind of racism and
to the degree that that's faulty in its
essence
i mean if the thing is worth doing then
by definition it's worth doing well and
if nothing is worth doing then we don't
do anything and there's nothing to talk
about and so the notion that excellence
is somehow associated with a given race
or a racial view is
preposterous and demoralizing
and but
and and also something that's greatly
detrimental
at least in principle to the very people
that
are supposed to be helped by such
doctrines
well yes
it's possible that the whiteness the
assault on white
up as people of the assault on
uh the western let's say the western
legacy
and that what is happening is a
a desire to enact that revenge i
referred to earlier
and a desire to
to take apart what what some of us
thought was actually an ideal
which is the ideal that the western
tradition
is not actually the preserve of white
people but it's a universal inheritance
and i say this repeatedly in the book
this is one way of looking at it is is
to say
one of the interesting things about
so-called
let's is a phrase i don't like to use
but let's say white culture western
culture
one of the remarkable things about it
has been
yes in its negative forms it has
attempted to force itself upon people it
is positive forms
it invites anyone who wants to be part
of it to share in it which is again not
the case with other cultures there is
there is no way even in let's say in the
political systems of any other country
outside of the west
if you were to migrate there from a
western country you would not be able to
work your your way up to the prime
ministership presidency or even the
cabinet of of most other countries in
the world if you if you were an outsider
the west is is is
specifically in our era exceptionally
open and believes that its own
inheritance its own traditions its own
political order its institutions not
just should be open but have to be open
to anybody who wants to be a part of
them
so that's
and and that ideal is one of the ones
that in the name of anti-racism is being
taken apart in our time she's saying no
no no these things only belong to the
white people and as i say in in uh
toward the end of the of the war on the
west wow are the conclusions that you
get to from their negative i mean
wow are the consequences of that down
the road negative because
and as i lay out as you know in quite a
lengthy passage
there is a there is a response to that
just waiting to be said
so
do you think
do you think that the core values of the
west are tenable and maintainable in the
absence of the
underlying religious substrate so i'm
i'm thinking about
jacques derrida for example and
derek daredev criticized what he called
the logocentrism
of the west
and its emphasis for example on binary
oppositions and
binary oppositions are the foundation of
computation so
maybe
criticizing that too deeply is unwise
but
in any case
the
it seems to me that the notion of
individual sovereignty is in some sense
a religious claim
and
this gets
you can think about the west one stream
of western thought is the enlightenment
and there's a secular element to that
but it emerged out of a deeper
religious tradition that has this
universalizing tendency and this
universalizing claim
um
[Music]
is it possible for the
then i would say to what degree are is
the assault on values that you see and
diagnose and assault on religious values
and
is it possible to formulate a defense
without simultaneously defending some of
these underlying religious presumptions
no i mean this is uh this is a german
journalist bottom forward is dilemma
isn't it the um
can you sustain a system that isn't
willing to to nurture the roots that
gave birth to the system
um and uh
it's probably the the biggest underlying
question of our era
uh the the the the
the claim has been some time yes of
course and i think that that yes of
course has been coming under significant
strain in recent years
as i said i mean it's it's um it's not
clear that the sanctity of the
individual is something that is
enforceable purely through human rights
doctrine and the court and the
international court system
yeah well it's not self-evident that
it's
fundamentally a rational claim it might
be instead something more like the
precondition for all claims that we
regard as rational which is a whole
an axiom rather than a conclusion
and and
axioms have to be accepted on faith by
definition right in
if you define faith as operation within
the system that the axioms give rise to
and
i've been trying to puzzle this out
deeply there's
the idea of the divine individual in the
west is associated with the idea of
logos and it's associated with the
notion as well that there's something
about speech in particular truthful
speech that is
fundamentally redemptive and it's
recognition of that i think that gives
rise to our notion that freedom of
speech is a cardinal value not because
it gives you the freedom to speak
exactly but because without that freedom
we can't
we can't think we can't yes we can't
improve our institutions
and and we can't get to truth that it
isn't it isn't a mural it isn't a merely
um
theoretical exercise
the point of the point of freedom of
speech freedom of inquiry and all these
things
was to get to a truth
it wasn't a game in itself
right it was a belief that there was
something to uncover at the end of that
process that was more than worth
right well when i talked to richard
dawkins recently about such things and
of course he's arguably the world's most
famous atheist but
i like talking to him and
i think dawkins is possessed by the
spirit of the truth
to a market degree and so then one of
the things i wonder is
is science itself possible in the
absence of the proposition that the
truth will set you free i don't think
that's a scientific proposition i think
it's a it's a philosophical or a
theological proposition
i mean this comes to one of the great
the great um
uh jokes against uh conservatives in
recent years uh i think i've said it to
you in private before jordan but not
publicly but that i mean one of the one
of the great jokes against conservatives
was that they tended to think that the
deconstructionists for instance would
inevitably stop at the borders of stem
remember for years people sort of have
risks and the fact that well you know
your your your degree in lesbian dance
theory you know you just wait till you
have to go out into the market and and
find a job with that useless degree but
these people actually the joke was on
the conservatives saying that they they
did all fine degree their
jobs they found them in hr departments
and they told everyone else how to
behave for the next generation so so um
and then there was this sort of joke
that the conservatives again had of sort
of you know it it'll stop at the borders
of stem because at some point the
bridges need to stay up
no
no turns out that if you've got a more
overriding uh theory and claim and
ambition and drive in your era
if the bridges do fall down it'll be
because of institutional racism and
constructional racism and much more and
it'll be because you didn't do it hard
enough it'll be just like the the
nonsense that everyone said in communism
look at look at the stuff of different
ways of knowing i mean this goes back
yeah i i am
a deep deep contempt for derrida as i do
for all of the deconstructionists not
just because it's so easy to deconstruct
and so hard to construct
but because of course the
deconstructionists always tried to
deconstruct everything apart from their
own university positions
um and
and uh derrida and code definitely
started some of this and it's led to
this this thing we now have one of the
things i described in the book of the
equitable maths nonsense
where we come once again to the
anti-white anti i would say also
anti-black actually
but certainly anti-western idea that
mathematics is an is a western construct
and that there are other ways of knowing
that exist and which must be brought
forth and you don't just get this in
maths and by the way i mean as i as
again as i lay out in remorseless detail
in the book this is this is being taught
in american schools this is being rolled
out in in school district after school
district in the u.s
the idea that in maths in stem in
general there are other ways of knowing
other than the scientific method
accurate mathematics things like showing
your workings is
an example of white uh supremacy and on
and on and on and this is completely
mainstream today to an extent that i
think will shock many readers
these things are effectively in the
realm of voodoo
because nobody ever explains what the
other ways of knowing are
um
let me give you an example
if you don't believe in the mathematical
method that actually happens to have
been refined in the west but poses
some of its ancestry to a considerable
indeed bewildering array of cultures
around the world why you can't say oh
that's interesting the west may have
refined it but it's it's got its
heritage elsewhere hurrah we're all able
to own it why instead of that you have
to say no this is a white supremacist
thing so we're going to come up with
other ways of knowing instead of
addition and subtraction in the normal
way of things what are the other ways of
knowing
what is this voodoo we're being told
never explained never explained other
than
you get this little hint sometimes that
it has something to do with
better
intuitiveness about the concerns of
others
and i give examples of this and
basically
you could also argue it's a sort of
feminization of certain things for
certain realms of study but essentially
that the
the white supremacists the male
patriarchal thing is all about the
answers and about accuracy and about
being on time even i mean all of these
to say that they're racist i hardly need
saying but all of these things are white
and therefore we need to look at these
other ways of knowing which are never
explained
but there's something
something which we're all meant to go
along with i mean
to say that this doesn't bear
um examination is is is to vastly
understate the matter
yeah well i think the stem types are
completely
defenseless against
all of this they tend to be apolitical
in their
machinations if they're credible
scientists incredible researchers almost
by definition because
they're busy
obsessively detailing out their
specialized concerns
and not paying attention to the broader
context which works fine if the broader
context is one in which their
narrow and specialized productive
pursuits are valued
but
fatal when that isn't the case and so
one of the questions that we're facing
now is
what are the
invisible ethical preconditions
for the successful practice of science
itself and
weirdly enough that's kind of a
postmodern question you know because the
postmodernists did insist to some degree
that
we exist within stories although they
don't believe in grand unifying
narratives which begs the question for
me then
what unites us
internally psychologically or socially
if there's no unifying narrative if
narrative is the fundamental answer
the narrative in which science
operates is something like
well the pursuit of truth is valuable in
and of itself
and
it's valuable because it's a benefit to
people at the individual level
and
as long as that's in place it can all be
ignored and science can act as if it's
something unto itself
and i know that's a tricky argument
because it does
veer in somewhat into the postmodern
direction
but
we wouldn't pursue science if we didn't
think the pursuit was valuable and
redemptive
yes
right
and was heading towards something but
yes yes
that can be attained by
go ahead can you can you say the same
thing about the humanities
can you say the same thing about art can
you say the same thing about metaphysics
can you say the same thing
about
politics or economics or anything else
and i think the answer in all of these
things is
that the priority of the era is
representation
not attainment of a goal that is worth
attaining other than representation
and
and and this is where we get to this
what i say in the war in the west is one
of the deep underlying
just questions we have to address which
is
is the game that our societies have
decided to play
worth playing
and does it mean that we effectively win
out in the end or not
and
let me flesh that out by saying what i
mean is
let's say that across america and all
other western societies
we managed to to completely nix the
representation game
and the diversity inclusion equity game
was just solved
and that every board in america and
every other western country canada
britain you name it every board had
exactly the right
representation or over representation of
minority groups
so that there was
more trans people on every board more
black people more minority ethnic people
on every board or exactly the percentage
that replicated the percentage in the
country
and that every board and every and every
workforce across every imaginable
discipline and every industry
exactly replicated of course is i don't
need to tell you the absurdity of this
but that you know you had exactly 50
percent female firefighters and
and exactly 50 percent of
the police were women and if in america
13 of the population the black and 13 of
the police are black and and under on
and on and on and the same with
engineers and the same with electricians
and the same with absolutely everybody
computer programmers a lot
let's say you get to there
do you beat china
i i don't know that the question's at
all clear the answers are all clear to
that question
um
my own suspicion is actually it's a game
that we're playing for politeness
reasons and for some justifiable reasons
in certain areas and i give the example
in the book saying actually
it makes sense to have a for instance a
police force that
represents the community
pretty accurately
um
but
do you actually need your uh for
instance your basketball teams or your
or your computer programmers all to also
completely accurately represent the
population
and to have complete representation it
doesn't seem to me that you'd win any
particular game from doing so other than
satisfying the game that the west has
decided to play for the time being
but at the end of that game well you win
if you win if you you win if you regard
holding those positions
as
a reward that's equivalent to privilege
rather than as the
opportunity to do something productive
in and of itself right and so because
that seems to be part of the
conceptualization is
while your job is a reward to be doled
out
rather than something that's productive
in relationship to valuable ends and you
mentioned the humanities earlier too
i don't think there is humanities
outside of the canon
so
science is nested inside an underlying
ethic that presumes that let's say the
universe is understandable that there's
some association between that and logic
that pursuing the truth in relationship
to knowledge of the world has this
redemptive quality and that there are
very careful ways of doing that but the
humanities is also nested
but
even in some sense more self-evidently
inside the idea of a cannon
and that cannon is traditional and if
you throw out the traditional canon i
think by definition you throw the
humanities
and
well i mean
as you know in the chapter on culture i
go into this
because
i i think by this stage it is clear that
there is not an aspect of western
culture that has not been
assaulted at such a fundamental and
dishonest level
but if you were to continue this game
there's just nothing left nothing
uh the british library in 2020 announced
that they were
um
going to create a list of
authors
whose work was in the british library
including manuscripts and important
documents by these authors who had some
connection to the slave trade or
colonialism
and they produced this sort of
black list of authors
including the late poet laureate ted
hughes who died in 1998
who was born in considerable poverty in
yorkshire in the 1930s
who had nothing to do with the british
empire and the british library claimed
that one of his ancestors in the 17th
century
had benefited from the slave trade i
mean this isn't even the sins of the
father debate anymore this is the sins
of the ancestor four centuries earlier
debate and by the way it turned out
among other things that the british
library can't even get researchers these
days because the research researchers
turned out to have
selected a person called nicholas ferrer
who actually was opposed to the slave
trade and wasn't an ancestor of ted
hughes so they they weirdly just decided
to posthumously defame somebody
uh and this isn't at all uncommon the
tate uh gallery in london
i i give an example one that i might
come on to is particularly painful to me
but there's an example of um one of the
masterpieces they have in there i don't
know if you know the work but it's uh
a beautiful painting called the
resurrection cucumber by stanley spencer
on the great mid-century british artists
and it's a huge vast canvas which the
tate is exceptionally lucky to have
um painted in the 1930s and it is a
depiction of the of the physical
resurrection of the dead at the day of
judgment and they're all coming out of
their tombs in the graveyard of his
local church in the village of cookhome
and it's a profoundly moving painting to
me i've always been
i used to occasionally my lunch time
just go to sit in front of this canvas
some of the dead coming out of the tombs
are recognizably apparently neighbors of
spencer's from his village
but he wanted to show the resurrection
of all humanity so he also includes you
know there are black men and women
coming out of some of the graves as well
he didn't have to do that but he wanted
to show the literal representation of
the actual physical resurrection well
the tate now has a descriptor beside
this sublime painting
saying that it is a racist painting
because whereas stanley spencer
accurately depicts his neighbors from
his village in england the black people
in the painting are generic black people
copied from national geographic magazine
of the time
well
stanley spencer didn't have any black
neighbors you know so what so what there
weren't any black people in his village
in the 1930s in england
and how dare these people but they've
done it now on everything
yet to be morally superior to a genius
they get to be maori superior to a
genius and but but what concerns me is
that they they they pull down a sublime
thing into their banal
monotone
uh utterly monomaniacal view
of of of the world which is that race is
the only thing that matters let me give
you one example example if i may because
it's particularly painful to me there's
a wonderful painter i'm very an artist
i'm very fond of called rex whistler
um
who uh
english artists from the early 20th
century everybody adored him he was
clearly an exceptionally lovable human
being and an exceptionally talented
artist and his first artwork was a mural
for the tape that he he did in his early
20s and he worked all around the clock
for months and months on end to complete
this mural called in pursuit of rare
meets it's a fantasy a beautiful fantasy
landscape and an arcadian landscape that
goes around all four walls of the
gallery
and a couple of years ago a group whose
whose name
was white pube
only consisting of a couple of people
decided that this mural was racist and
they decided it because of two figures
one of whom was a chinese figure they
said was generic and the other was
because in one corner of the forest in
one of the bits of the rest of a tiny
figure about two inches high is a is a
young black boy clearly in distress
being pulled on a chain by a woman in a
white fully frock
now clearly rex whistler he always
included sort of ugly things like this
as a drowning child a white rounding
white child elsewhere in it it's clearly
et in arcadia ego
you know that's clearly what he's saying
he was always saying this all of his
work always included this you know
there'd be a two more he'd even painted
himself in things as a lowly street
sweeper you know and he had a wonderful
sense of humor and a wonderful
and dark sense of the carbon nature of
all things even in arcadia
this was decided two years ago by the
tape to be a racist painting and they
have closed the room until further
notice they looked into whether or not
they could actually remove after 100
years actually remove this from the
walls of the gallery
and they it seems that they can't
because part of it's on plaster so
they've locked the room
and the reason i mind this among many
other reasons
is because they have posthumously
declared rex whistler to be a racist
they said that he has he reflected the
racist attitudes of his time
rex whistler died on his first day in
action in normandy in 1944.
how dare these people do this
how dare they do it to everybody in our
past
to all of our heroes to all of our
artistic heroes how dare they say that
the story of the west is purely a story
of
racism
and xenophobia and and colonialism and
slavery how dare they not even bother to
weigh that up as i say in one point in
the book weigh it up against just
let you know let's name a few cities
paris
florence rome venice just for starters
how dare they not be able to even weigh
up the achievements that have come from
this allegedly
unremittingly terrible past but worse
than that and the point i really wanted
to make jordan is
what they are driving us to and i feel
it very very strongly myself is
how dare you do this to our ancestors
how dare you do this to all of our
heroes and then the follow-on thought is
this
if you have no respect for my ancestors
i see no reason why i should have
respect for yours
if you have no respect for my past and
my culture
i don't see why i should continue to say
that i have respect for yours
if you have nothing good to say about me
why should i
have anything good to say about you
and what i suggest is that in the west
at the moment we are in a potentially
short holding pattern a holding pattern
based on politeness
or as kenneth clark lord clarke of
civilization put it that fundamental
aspect of western culture courtesy
we are in a period of courtesy
where we have been willing to say
[Music]
okay you can keep rampaging through the
past of the west and assaulting my
ancestors and insulting my predecessors
and saying all of these negative things
about my past and i am pretending for
the time being or saying out of courtesy
that you can do this and i will put up
with it for a time
and i will even say and there are these
other ways of knowing and so on but
there is a moment there where that
absolutely stops and as i say at the end
of the book as you know jordan i say
there's a very clear place where you can
do that
the courtesy stops at a certain point
and it stops when you say you know what
this politeness seems not to be working
for us
so let's go for the impolite things and
the impolite things that can be said are
legion and nobody should want to go
there but that's where we're being led
so these great cities that you
point to and the great achievements that
went along with them to me they're the
consequence of
the manifestation of the best of the
human spirit universally speaking that
was made possible by societies that
recognize the existence of such of the
best
and so that was a precondition
and to and to associate them
in some sense with
western culture with white culture
and then to associate them with nothing
but the spirit
of oppression
is to
simultaneously deny
that that spirit exists and can produce
things of
universal transcendent value and i can't
see that that's going to be good
for anyone except for people who can
make moral hay of that in the short term
to ratchet themselves up
what
uh to produce for themselves positions
of authority that would not be available
to them if they weren't able to
weaponize guilt and claim the moral
upper hand
yes well so let let me ask you another
question
one of the
accusations that's levied at me
from
fairly frequently is that
my concern about such things which i
would say in many ways is similar to
yours
isn't
is evidence of my
i'm exaggerating this is illusory none
of this is actually happening um
point to the evidence
exactly and i think well i see it in the
spread of such ideas in the universities
and then downstream into culture but
people aren't particularly awake to that
fact i mean in my home province in
ontario there's a bill
that purports to be anti-racists that
that's going to transform the entire
education system
by fiat into
a system that
is part of the war on the west let's say
and and that and people who conduct that
war will be rewarded for that
how do you know that
why do you believe that this is a
serious concern
well because as i say they
they decided to come for absolutely
everything
because it's not just a judeo-christian
tradition of the west but the
enlightenment tradition of the west too
it's the religious tradition and the
secular tradition
it's
it's the it's it's the american
politicians and leaders and presidents
who were on the side of the south in the
civil war and the ones who are on the
side of the north
it it comes for people who owned slaves
and those who who were opposed to
slavery
it comes from people who were
in favor of empire and those who were
against empire
it comes for those who lived in the arab
empire and everyone who lived before it
and everyone who lived after it the
people who lived in the era of slavery
and all of the people who live after it
it it's so comprehensive and
i mean you mentioned canada just now
there's a
highly pertinent example
which is the the
that insane spate of church burning that
went on in your native country uh a year
ago
um just to remind people um as a clay
there was a claim that
graves of indigenous children were found
beside what had been a school and it had
been run by the catholic church
and
that these were graves of children
therefore murdered by the catholic
church and in no time prominent figures
in canada i list some of them in the
book and you know some of them as well
jordan start to tweet out things like
burn it all down
and churches including indigenous built
churches in canada
go up in flames
across parts of the country well
in what other situation would that have
been regarded as being
something you just shrug off and by the
way to date
no evidence has been produced of these
alleged mass graves it happened on the
basis of an investigation using
ultrasound that turns out not to have
yet produced one grave
so
we are so primed
we are so primed at this idea that for
instance the catholic church who which i
am not a
you know defender to the death or
anything but the the institutions like
that are so
evil that they
deliberately killed children in
countries like canada hid them in mass
graves and now you can burn down the
churches if you want what other
religious tradition in canada would be
would be allowed to be treated like that
in the present or would it be
just sort of brush it off that it
happened
it happens all around us and it's not
just in the academies as you know it's
spilt out many years ago it's everywhere
and it now has this completely
um
physical manifestation on the streets
when the so-called 1619 riots kicked off
and just reminded us this is the 1619
project which tries to completely
reframe all of american history to say
that the heroic story of america is not
a story of heroism it's one of slavery
and subjugation which is why they start
in 1619 when the riots after the death
of george floyd began the murder of
george floyd began in 2020 somebody says
they should be called the 16
riots and the woman who who fronted the
1619 project at the new york times so
we're not talking about some
kooky far out fringe publication says
the 1619 riots
i'd be honored
and these are the riots where
sure they start to pull down statues of
general lee okay
don't wouldn't go to wouldn't go to the
uh the wall for that one at all uh but
then it's jefferson and then it's
lincoln
and then it's absolutely every damn
figure in american history who ends up
getting assailed
well
that's no longer
a
theoretical thing that's not just
students reading derrida
that's not just an ex that's not just
papers on foucault this is the
manifestation of some of their thought
often by people who've never read them
but this is long ago the spilling out
even of their own thought
simply into this thing where the era
decides everything in our own past must
be scoured
what's to come after
they don't tell us any more than they
tell us what the other ways of knowing
might be
what are you trying to accomplish with
the book douglas do you think apart from
clarifying your own thoughts
quite a number of things
one is to alert people to the scale of
what is being attempted against
western countries
another is to point to the unfairness of
it
the simple unfairness of it
the unjustness of it
another is to arm people with the i
think reasonable and correct rebuttals
to it
to remind people of
the context of history
and the context of the rest of the world
so that we get ourselves and our own
past in a proper light
and get the rest of the world in a
proper light i mean you have an
interesting you have an interesting
interlude in there so there's four
chapters race history religion and
culture and there's three interludes uh
china reparations and maybe the most
interesting or one the one that struck
me most particularly was an interlude on
gratitude
and so you elevate that as a moral
virtue and and
it's the antithesis in some sense of of
of a resentment for history gratitude
talk about that for a bit why did that
why that value particularly
well as you know it's one you've thought
about a lot and spoken written about a
lot is it's one that a number of my
friends have um
and i i just
it's been one of the underlying things
in my life and whenever i'm asked to
sort of explain as it were
why i come to some of the conclusions i
come to on things i i come back to this
this term
um
[Music]
my our late friend roger scrutin one
that i think actually the last thing he
wrote i quote in the book was a diary
for the spectator where he reflected on
his last year of his life
and roger said to
to approach death is is to approach what
what life really means
and what it means is gratitude
um now that was the last thing he wrote
um
i thought about it a lot i i quote
dostoyevsky as you know from
the brothers karamazov where the devil
the devil is incapable of is incapable
of gratitude
um which i i is it is deeply telling and
brilliant
right exactly well that was also penned
at about the same time that nietzsche
was pointing to resentment as the
driving force behind movements for
example that later became
revolutionary marxism
yes and
and the more and and outlining the moral
hazard associated with that
exactly and and
nietzsche and some other writers who
come after him on resentment i i've
spent a lot of time reading in recent
years i think it's i think that
resentment is is
along with that desire for revenge in
the name of justice one of the
absolutely underlying drivers of our
time
many of the great philosophers realize
this resentment is a terrifically strong
driver
and
and as
again as nietzsche and others said um
it it's a terrific way to avoid any
culpability
because there's only the only way as you
well know the only the the only way to
turn around resentment
apart from gratitude
would be for the person of resentment to
recognize that there is a reason why
they feel resentment and that there is a
person who is responsible for the things
that they are angry about but that the
person is themselves
this is of course such
a profoundly disturbing uh
life disturbing
thing to acknowledge that almost nobody
deeply embedded in resentment can
uh
why we always look for excuses we always
put it on other people it's so hard to
take responsibility ourselves for what
has not gone wrong in our own life so
much harder compared to
putting it on any other group of people
or another individual a person we
believe has done us wrong or a group we
believe have done us wrong it's so easy
to manipulate our species against other
groups of people my god what's the
history of the jews but a history of
people pouring their resentments onto
this
tiny group of people
for daring to continue to exist and
thrive across societies um you know
the history of anti-semitism is that as
it is in our own days the great
explanation for how where some people
can pour their resentment but but the
but the main thing you that you that you
have to count and i've i've long said
this to conservatives in my own country
and elsewhere is the the
you have to address things at an equally
deep level
and when people say uh i can't remember
if we've talked about this before but
when people say for instance um
how will the right respond to the left
on this issue you very often see things
like they know well we'll need to do
more house building on uh brownfield
sites or something like this and you and
and i i think you're mad i mean you're
you're countering resentment
you can't do that with a bit of
bureaucracy
now how can you how can you counter
resentment it is only i believe by
gratitude
it is only by
completely inverting that sentiment and
i think that in our own lives as well as
in societies this is eminently possible
you and i both know this you can you can
you can stand in front of a painting
and you can you could endlessly work out
the cost that that painting had had had
what the cost of it had been
what the cost of it had been for
instance if were the people who worked
in the workshop of this master
adequately paid
where there were
paints that were sourced from specific
minerals
were those minerals justly acquired and
were people along every stage of the
process justly rewarded for providing
the material you could break that down
endlessly or you could stand back and
marvel at the madonna of the rocks you
know you could stand in front of
michelangelo's pieta
and you could think about
what the workmen who got the piece of
marble out of the quarry went through
and whether they were adequately paid
and whether they had all the life
choices necessary
to for them to be able to decide whether
they wanted to be quarriers
in marble
or you can stand back and marvel at
michelangelo's pieta
you you can do this in every city in
europe you can look at venice and say
this was a trading city where
not everyone was always adequately
rewarded for their labor
or you can marvel at venice
you can you can do this on absolutely
every everything can be deconstructed to
this utmost point at which you cannot
see the value in anything because you
claim to be looking for the for the
for the basically for the checks and the
bills historically speaking and in the
present day and it is such a
a reductive
mean-minded
obsessive way that our era actually is
looking at things it actually is tearing
everything apart in this way it actually
is looking for racism everywhere it is
looking for colonialism and slavery and
blame and guilt and i just say how about
turning that around and saying just have
some damn gratitude for what you found
yourself living among
and
as i say all i can
all i can suggest is that our age in the
west has gone through a vast context
collapse and i'm very struck by the fact
that many many people if not a majority
who come to the west from outside of the
west do not share this ravenous
hatred
uh i have a friend who's a school
teacher in a a school in london who has
said before that
that one of the best ways to make sure
that a pupil who is misbehaving as it
well playing up
um
in a very
uh
very dominantly you know immigrant
background school one of the best ways
to make sure that uh they change their
life attitude is if they are taken back
to the country of origin at some point
in a school holiday by their parents
because
they might not particularly like they
may they may be told in their school in
new york or in london or or ontario that
they are living in a patriarchal racist
society but wow when they go back and
see their first and second cousins in
bangladesh they might they they come
back with a a different view
my view in general is is that we in the
west have undergone a massive context
collapse about the nature of our own
past our own societies i think we have
to turn it around i don't think it's
sustainable to continue to war on
ourselves and on every part of our own
history not least also because we
deserve the right to have heroes and
heroic narratives and things of which
we're proud we absolutely have that
right as every other society in the
world does
so
i'm trying to
do a more reasonable audit
on an era which i think has been deeply
unreasonable to itself
as i say this is a this is a western on
western crime that is being committed
it is completely possible to mend it and
that's why this very very depressing
subject matter in some ways i try as you
know by the end of the book to show
people actually this is positive this is
a way out and these are the ways out
these are the ways in which you can try
to turn
the ear of resentment into a personal
and wider appreciation
of gratitude
that of getting things into a proper
order and of getting things into a
proper sense of themselves because my
god we need it
i've been trying to conceptualize
gratitude as a form of courage
no well because there's
there's evidence for tragedy and
atrocity obviously and
everywhere and that can make you despair
that gratitude is also part of
separating the wheat from the chaff
right is that
you want to
you want to appreciate the things that
are of high value
and so and i i wanted to ask maybe close
with one more question it's a
complicated question maybe i'll put it
in two parts
you know in in the biblical narrative
the first two human beings that
emerge in any real sense are cain and
abel
they're the first
who are born rather than directly
created and
it's a rather depressing
beginning point because they're
they're fragile brothers
and
cain is bitter and resentful
and abel makes the sacrifices that are
acceptable to god and flourishes and
it's because of that flourishing that
cain
decides to destroy him
and
the depth psychology that i've read and
the literary criticism tradition that's
emerged from that suggests in some sense
that
those are the earliest manifestations of
two patterns of
deeply rooted patterns of behavior
one you might regard as the spirit of
abel
and the other the spirit of cain
and
our era is characterized by this
tremendous increase in the speed of
communication
and it seems to me that that's produced
an exaggeration of this battle
and it seems also to me in some sense
that it is a theological battle it's
it's
it's
the anti-logos aspect of it is a
theological battle
and that
it has to be addressed in some sense at
that level
and so i guess what i'm asking you is
well first of all what you think of
those ideas and second
if this is
how this may have changed your views on
what would you say the necessary truth
of
the religious suppositions that underlie
that notion of the sovereignty of the
individual
i guess that's
um
yes i mean i uh
i laid out in the strange death of
europe what i think of as being not just
my own but certainly modern europe's
current malays in regards to
the christian tradition
uh
the difficulty of it
i i think as you've also said in the
past i've i've
often tried to live with what cardinal
ratzinger when he was still cardinal
ratzinger uh it said as the invitation
to live as though god exists which i
thought was a deeply brilliant
um
invitation
a very generous invitation actually from
a soon-to-be pope
um
and uh
i i think as i've i've expressed a
number of times recently that
that in any case uh
you you need a tradition to come from
in order to know what the others are and
that
the the modern idea that as it were you
can splash around among all of the
faith traditions of the world as a child
and come out
more roundly formed seems to me to be
doing
everything exactly in reverse and that
that really the way in which a child to
be read is in one tradition so that they
can then go out having been versed in
one tradition and know the others
discover the others as they go along but
that the complexity of that is something
that only an adult can go through you
you
know you can only understand the things that
the traditions have in common if you
know the one that you've come from and
you can only actually admire them
other traditions on their own terms
really if you know and and and have some
reverence for the one that you've come
from otherwise it's all just a sort of
mishmash of
yoga-like banalities i i'm not so i i
certainly know how much i owe personally
to this tradition and i know my
deeply um
complex conflicted and inadequate
uh
answers to it i um
it's
you know i
i often have to fall back on quotes but
um
i i was
i'm not i'm not jewish i'm christian by
upbringing but um
i remember something i mentioned earlier
late friend rabbi sachs he once said to
me he said that isaiah berlin
friend was once asked uh
what it meant to be a jew and he said to
be a jew is to have a sense of of
history
and uh
um and jonathan sachs said isaiah was
almost right and he said and i said what
do you mean he said i corrected him he
said to be jewish is to have a sense of
memory
um
it's a it's a pretty good clarification
um
i think one has a role in society to
have a sense of memory
and
in that case if you're from a society
like i am like you are that memory is
absolutely god haunted
and christ haunted biblically biblically
haunted and there's no way around that i
don't resist it i don't i certain and i
i also i long ago came to the same
conclusion that roger scrutin did and he
encouraged me to which was at least
don't war on it you know um
and there's many other things that are
worth warring on but unless and less and
until
the christian religion was to return to
the stage of
that it was at in parts of europe in the
15th and 16th centuries there's no no
need to i don't see the
the episcopalian church in america for
instance as particularly requiring my um
my critique
um so i do have a um
i have a complex attitude towards it but
i
um
i try to remain i try to remain in
dialogue with the religion is the way i
would i would put it
and not to close the door i think that's
uh
that's one of the i think i told you
when we met possibly that
the
the word israel means
those who wrestle with god
yes
yes and that's that's very interesting
as far as i'm concerned
yes
that's the nature of unbelief in some
senses to wrestle with the notion of
what constitutes the highest virtues
what the the former bishop of edinburgh
was a sort of secularist himself by the
end of his career but a deeply
distinguished and humanist figure um
called richard holloway once rather
beautifully said that the everyone
assumes that the opposite of um
of of uh faith is is doubt but the
opposite of no sorry the opposite of
doubt is faith but it isn't its
certainty
um
certainty is is the um
is the problem in that in that in that
mix of absolute perhaps having
conflicted views is inevitable if if not
necessary
um
as for cain label um
is it isn't one of the many things in
that story the fact that as so often in
the early books of the bible the torah
that you're being reminded that you're
both people i mean that
that
that everyone has both of these things
in their hearts and that just as we
the the the path yeah
both these paths are always open to all
of us
isn't that what we're one of the things
that we're being told
well we're we're always tempted by
the desire to get away with insufficient
sacrifices
you know to cut corners and to not
do things as well
and at as much cost as we might
we're all tempted by
what would you say the spirit of revenge
that we might allow to inhabit us if we
became sufficiently bitter we're all
tempted to tear down idle our ideals
because they also simultaneously judge
us we're all tempted to shake our fist
at god
but if that spirit gets up gets the
upper hand well the consequence for cain
is that his sin is so much that he
cannot bear it
and it be i believe that if we in the
west tear down everything of value
because we've given
too much sway to the spirit of
resentment and revenge the consequences
us for us all will be
something so cataclysmic that we won't
be able to bear it
and i i couldn't agree more and we come
back to this thing that we don't know
what it would be
if the men of resentment had their way
in what they're doing and pulled
everything down as they are trying to
pull down all of our stories all of our
heroes all of our history all of our
culture read our culture as a story not
of
admiration for the world and learning
from the world but actually theft from
the world if they did this on everything
and succeeded as they're doing at the
moment what is it exactly at the end of
this other than the again the other ways
of knowing what is it that lies there
and the one answer you can get for
people is essentially a version of that
thing that
tom wolf
um
described in radical chic you know the
uh the essay on the the party at the
bernstein's apartment in new york in the
early seventies that the burns that
leonard bernstein his wife threw for the
black panthers and of course thomas
wolfe tommel fantastically destroys this
obscene
obscene event where the where the the uh
liberal elite of new york are having
canapes listening to these
revolutionaries describing how they want
to destroy and pull down the society
they're in and there's a wonderful
moment in it where i think zotto
preminger one of bernstein's friends is
sitting in his in his chair and he says
to under the panthers but what are you
going to do once you have pulled down
all of the existing structures but but
what are you going to do and he keeps
pushing this panther on it
on this until this black panther says
you can't put a blueprint on the future
man
and leonard bernstein leans forward in
his chair and says you mean you're just
gonna wing it
and that's really what we're dealing
with we're dealing with people who don't
know what they're going to do they're
going to pull everything down and then
wing it
well if we
undermine
that which unites us
right and if we're united around
something like recognition of the value
of the individual the divine sovereignty
of the individual let's say
if we pull that down and destroy it then
it's the group it's the war of every
conceivable group against every other
conceivable group
that's the only alternative that i can
see because there's an infinite number
of
arbitrarily oppressed groups
absolutely and and i would just add a
coder to that which is
you know i think people should be very
aware careful of what they wish for in
this
you know as you know at the end of the
the war in the west i say you know of
all of the unpalatable answers the one
coming the way of the people who want to
make this racial is
is worse than any you know
it would consist of saying this thing
that you believe
is so appalling right we've been
courteous enough
end of courtesy
why don't we go to the aboriginal
peoples or the first nations peoples for
any vaccines
why don't we find other ways of knowing
for cancer cures
why are all of these things
products of the thing that you say you
hate
and the people you ki
for politeness is sake everyone says can
also contribute and do in certain ways
but are not better than this
that the other ways of knowing are
actually worse
and then if you say oh and by the way
that's not universal after all because
you've told us it isn't it's just ours
wow is the 21st century hell
well
as far as i can tell from delving into
it that
that the end goal of the spirit of cain
is hell
yes right yes and we've been warned
about that for a very long time
and still have background
yes well you the 20th century might not
have been enough
i hope it was that's
that's a a horrible
horrible thought but i agree i agree
so to
this book is coming out april you said
26 26
so
it describes
the battle of ideas that currently
is tearing our culture apart and i would
say
in some real sense destabilizing the
entire world
and so people can read it and they can
draw their own conclusions and
see their own way forward but
it's an alarm bell and
it should be ringing loud
anything else mr murray
no just to remember i just just i would
just add since you did say at the
beginning that it was very depressing
it's also quite amusing if i say so
myself
and i have to put in i have to put in
that plug
i agree that what i describe is highly
depressing
but it is it is as i say i try to show a
way out and i do actually try to give
readers some fun along the way and you
can't not because some of what i'm
attacking is so reasonable
that um once again when i was doing the
audio book as i was for the mans of
crowds there were points i had to say to
the sound engineer i'm sorry i just the
reason i'm laughing so much i promise is
not it's not my own jokes it's the
things i'm reading when you read them
out loud are so even more ridiculous
than they are on the page
but um
yeah it may be um gloomy in places but
there is fun along the way
good to talk to you again
always great to see you jordan thank you
[Music]
[Music]
you